avec nous jean boulet ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la solidarité
sociale merci d'être là monsieur goulet
bonjour d'autant plus que les bonnes
nouvelles sont assez rare ces temps-ci
on parle surtout de licenciements mais
vous avez insisté sur le fait
aujourd'hui que même si à des
licenciements
le phénomène la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
ça existe encore au québec où est tout à
fait rappelons nous que au début de la
pandémie on est perdu quand même un
certain nombre d'emplois peu près huit
cent vingt mille globalement mais l'on
ne récupère et on est en mode de reprise
des activités économiques
est on encore 250 mille emplois à
récupérer mais ce qui est quand même
assez important de souligner c'est que
cohabitent un phénomène de de chômage
dans certains secteurs qui sont beaucoup
plus affectés par la pandémie et ya
encore de la rareté de main-d'oeuvre
dans des secteurs en reprise notamment
les technologies de l'information la
santé bien sûr le domaine de la
construction
c'est des secteurs qui sont névralgiques
pour l'économie du québec et il ya
encore un phénomène de rareté de
main-d'oeuvre donc on est vraiment en
mode action pour tenir compte de ces
deux réalités là qu'ils se côtoient en
mode action qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire monsieur goulet ce qu'on veut
inciter des travailleurs d'un secteur où
il ya des gens qui sont licenciés à à
changer d'activité à les combler les
besoin dans d'autres secteurs oui
absolument il faudra certainement
accompagner les chômeurs pandémique vers
les secteurs où il ya de la demande
il y aura un processeur certainement de
requalification de la main d'oeuvre pour
permettre à ces personnes là de répondre
aux besoins des secteurs qui sont en
effervescence où une rareté de
main-d'oeuvre donc on va s'assurer de
les accompagner et bien sûr dans les
secteurs où une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
on va mettre à jour nos mesures actives
d'emploi pour aider ces entreprises là à
combler les postes vacants se référer
aux technologies d'information le comité
sectoriel de main d'oeuvre qui est
supervisé par la commission des
partenaires du marché du travail au
québec me rappelaient qu'ils avaient
selon les dernières données à peu près
6500 postes vacants dans le domaine des
technologies de l'information et des
communications faux est donc un action
sur ces deux fronts
c'est particulier parce que oui d'un
secteur à l'autre des situations
différentes mais dans un même secteur je
pense celui de l'hôtellerie par exemple
c'est par région que la réalité pour la
même on manque de main-d'oeuvre je pense
à la gaspésie par exemple tandis qu'à
montréal les travailleurs n'ont pas
d'emploi qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
arrimer ou équilibrer les choses
je pense qu'il faut avoir une approche
asymétrique faut tenir compte des
réalités des spécificités régionales
évidemment ici à montréal le
centre-ville est affecté de façon
différente notamment en raison du
télétravail et qui était une façon
beaucoup plus sanitaire de travailler
mes yeux des impacts quand même au
centre-ville pour les commerces les
services les hôtels les restaurants et
donc le phénomène de rareté ou de
besoins de main d'oeuvre est différent
de ce à quoi on assiste dans plusieurs
régions non seulement en gaspésie mais
les québécois prennent leurs vacances au
québec font dans les régions et on le
constate moi j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'aller dans quelques régions durant ma
période
cance et j'ai réalisé à quel point les
québécois redécouvre elle québec soit
c'est extrêmement bénéfique pour notre
économie pour notre fierté comme
québécois québécoise ça nous permet de
réaliser à quel point et des beaux
environnements puis qu'on peut profiter
vraiment de nos vacances ici chez nous
au québec
je compare le secteur agricole monsieur
boulet et vous avez lancé au début de
l'été un programme votre pari c'est
d'attirer des québécois dans les champs
le bilan qu'on en fait aujourd'hui c'est
que ça fait pas fonctionné aussi bien
que prévu
qu'est ce qui a fait défaut mais il ya
eu quand même certains hommes
d'étudiants étudiants qui ont répondu à
l'appel
peut-être un peu moins que ce qu'on
avait anticipé il y avait bien sûr le
phénomène découlant de la pcu de la
prestation canadienne d'urgence qui
s'appliquait pour les étudiants qui a
probablement eu un certain impact
les travailleurs étrangers temporaires
ont cependant été beaucoup plus au
rendez vous il ya eu un nombre plus
important que ce qu'on anticipait donc
on on a évidemment toujours des besoins
dans le domaine agricole
mais je pense que cet appel au chant là
ont été une nouvelle opportunité de
faire un appel aux québécois puis leur
faire réaliser à quel point le domaine
alimentaire
c'est important qu'on ait notre
autonomie puis qu'on soit en mesure de
répondre à nos besoins avec nos fruits
et nous laisser ça mais les agriculteurs
les bilans qu'ils en font c'est pour les
récoltes là ils seront pas en mesure de
faire tout le travail qu'ils espéraient
qu'est ce qu'on va faire oui tout à fait
il ya eu un manque de main d'oeuvre pour
certaines entreprises du secteur
agricole
c'est une année qui est exceptionnel on
a eu à s'adapter on en tire des leçons
et je pense qu'on va faire ce qui
s'impose l'année prochaine et on va
s'assurer d'accompagner ces entreprises
là c'est un domaine qui est vraiment
vital pour le québec assez bien préparé
l'année prochaine peut-être il va
falloir penser aussi à l'automne on
parle du coach mario d'une 2
deuxième vague le scénario de
licenciements massifs en corse s'est pas
écarté au québec là il y en a eu des
licenciements dépendamment de certains
secteurs comme je le mentionnais qui ont
été plus affectés par la pandémie ya eu
des licenciements collectifs
il y en aura éventuellement d'eau dans
certains secteurs mais ce qu'il faut
faire actuellement puis les québécois
l'ont bien compris sont extrêmement
discipliné il respecte les normes de
distanciation porte les équipements
notamment les masques dans les
restaurants dans les commerces dans leur
vie quotidienne ça selon moi c'est la
meilleure préparation qu'on peut avoir
pour limiter les impacts négatifs d'une
potentielle seconde vague et au québec
évidemment on a appris énormément comme
un peu partout sur la planète pour le
matériel médical pour le réseau de la
santé pour les préposés aux
bénéficiaires
vous savez qu'on en a à peu près dix
mille qui sont en formation on voit être
beaucoup mieux près donc il faut se
préparer faut planifier en tenant compte
de tous les scénarios envisageables
beaucoup de défis pour tous à l'automne
merci beaucoup monsieur blé merci
beaucoup madame st-arnaud au plaisir